alors les roulettes qui font aussi la
joie des adeptes de la luge à villard de
lans dans le vercors un ancien
compétiteur des jeux olympiques
d'albertville s'est lancé dans
l'aventuré
frissons garantis pour les touristes qui
s'y essaye virginie ficher hellip il est
trop grand prétend
240 mètres de glisse à 70 km heure de
pointe de la luge sans glace nilan
affûté mais avec des bolides de
compétition tout de même montés sur
roulettes
c'est tout bête alors
proportionnellement ça va un petit peu
moins vite et là messieurs ces jeux télé
ça ne verrait pas la différence
s'inquiète une sait pas ne verrait pas
la différence
par contre la grosse différence kia pour
quelqu'un qui sait en faire c'est qu'il
ya beaucoup moins de jeu latéral c'est à
dire de dérapages possibles dans le
parcours
l'idée a germé dans la tête de l'ancien
les jeux olympiques il y a trois ans
avec son père ils ont réalisé cette
piste en fibre de verre et résine
polyester 1500 heures de travail plus
tard le circuit donne quelques
palpitations ou vacanciers casse cou
pour piloter en appui sur la jambe
gauche
quand vous tournez sur la droite ouais
et avec l'épaule en appui comme ça il en
tient qu on voit le core model temps
faire tout ça 2800 tour par descente les
roulettes encaisse le coeur des
touristes aussi ya l'estomac qui fait
des noeuds et puis la parole d'un wagon
verra je vous dirais comme si on était
sur nan elle est content qu'on glisse
avec des skis se sont allongés et qu'on
est sur un canapé
à la fin du moins l'équipe de france de
luge elle-même viendra s'entraîner ici
en attendant les champions voici la
longue glissade grandeur nature à
prouver qu'ils sont décidément tout le
monde est essoufflé